[Music]
why don't we are quickly taking over the
world and our hearts but you won't
believe some of their secrets stay tuned
to find out what these boys look for in
their perfect girl don't forget to hit
that notification about to never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
now let's check out why don't we boys
secrets High School Musical in an
interview with Seventeen magazine
why don't we boys were asked who is most
likely to know all the lyrics to High
School Musical although the question was
clearly meant to be an embarrassing one
we're just really not sure why this is
so embarrassing but hey it's a secret so
we're adding it to our video because
it's so adorable first the boys are
trying to figure out which member would
sing the lyrics most often but what
happens next is absolutely fantastic
the boys basically end up singing random
lyrics from all three movies and
honestly it's the best thing you've ever
seen Jonah said we're all in this
together
[Music]
which of course relates to one of the
best High School Musical songs ever the
band members then joined in with their
own favorite HSM songs they sing pretty
much all of our faves except they
sounded way better than we ever will
needless to say this was far from
embarrassing but it was just one of
those adorable moments that makes the
voice so cute
come on anyone who knows any High School
Musical lyrics is instantly 10 times
cooler and why don't we boys are
definitely cool the most selfies we all
have that friend that just won't stop
taking selfies seriously what did this
world do before selfies came along come
to think of it selfies were always a
thing weren't they we just made them
better with filters okay back to the
point we all know why don't we boys are
extremely good-looking so naturally
their selfies are nothing but perfection
don't believe us
just check out one of their instagrams
the boys rarely have a bad selfie day
and you can clearly see that from their
feed but the person that takes the most
selfies is in the fans opinion Zac they
even said he'll take several selfies
before finally deciding on one to post
on his instead and if you look at his
insta you'll see that his selfie game is
definitely on point although he's been
pointed out by other band members it
looks like the entire band is pretty
much nailing the whole selfie game
whether it's selfies with their fans by
themselves or just with the band these
boys really do know how to take good
pictures are we jealous but just a
little bit but not as jealous as we are
at the fact that these boys met their
man-crush crush on Ed Sheeran find
someone that talks about you the way why
don't we boys talk about Ed Sheeran
seriously these boys are really really
inspired by this iconic musician we
can't really blame them ed Sheeran is
pretty awesome they seem to always love
talking about their crush for Edie and
they actually managed to meet him
several times but it's not just a crush
the boys actually admitted to emulating
his performance techniques
- he's a unanimous admiration by every
single why don't remember and we have a
feeling these boys have an edge here
enshrine somewhere on their tour bus
avery admitted that Edie was his
inspiration for even picking up a guitar
and start going for it they also gave a
lot of credit to Ed when it comes to
their songwriting spam
point and really just have a great work
ethic isn't this just the most inspiring
thing ever wait it gets better
the boys of course also met Edie
backstage at one of I heart media's
Jingle Ball events the best part was
Edie ran into them like he'd already
know who they were
Daniel said that he acted really cool
and grounded giving you a feeling you
weren't even talking to one of the
biggest singers on the planet how cute
damn Diana collection every why don't we
member has a unique personality but
people notice something about Zach he
loves his bandanas in fact the boys
revealed that zach has a huge bandana
collection this reminds us of the time
Camilla Kibeho
was still in fifth harmony and she was
rockin all those hair bows she
definitely gave Jojo C wah a run for her
money
and just like amulet Zach has a hair
accessory of his own sure it's not as
cute as a bow but it definitely makes
him a million times cooler you can
actually get a bandana on why don't we
the fish'll merch a website which is
pretty awesome if you use why don't we
--za fishel merch hashtag they will also
feature you on their website wearing a
bandana it's unclear just how many
bandanas Zach actually owns but we can
just imagine him trying to pick out
every single bandana for their world
tour he also does a lot of bragging on
how his bandanas are way cooler than
anyone elses Oh Zach never grow out of
your bandanas please obsessed with
Chipotle every singer seems to have a
food obsession John Lennon had a real
obsession with jaffa cakes
during his beetle years Selena Gomez
admitted to eating popcorn with pickles
and drinking the pickle juice from the
jar Elvis Presley once eat a sandwich
with 40,000 calories the list goes on
and on and yep why don't we boys are
pretty much obsessed with Chipotle it's
the band's go to restaurant and they
admitted there's nothing better than a
good old Chipotle we frequently mention
it whenever the answer any questions
regarding their favorite food so the
love seems to be pretty real Chipotle
Twitter account even responded to Daniel
who said he was on his way to the
restaurant for the fifth time this week
in an adorable exchange the restaurant
replied back asking why don't we all go
why don't we band account replied back
that they would walk a million miles to
find their way to Chipotle Ed Sheeran
watch out these boys are
having a real romance with an actual
restaurant we're totally here for this
adorable exchange the only downside is
we're really craving Chipotle right now
hidden talents it seems that every
superstar has a couple of hidden talents
up their sleeves of course why don't we
boys are no different we absolutely love
it when they sing but the boys also
admitted they can do a ton of other
things some of them might be
embarrassing but Italian is a talent so
we won't really judge for example Jonah
admitted that he's extremely skilled at
knitting and crocheting which is pretty
amazing we can totally see him doing
that when he's bored on the tour bus but
he's not the only one with an amazing
talent Daniel for example is really
skilled at Chinese yo-yo that also comes
in handy when you're fighting boredom
doesn't it but the one that seems to
have the most skills is definitely Jack
he's one of those people that will do
something until they're really good at
it and because of that jack and
skateboard snowboard play basketball
guitar play piano and more he's
definitely a man of many talents and
we're sure that will come in handy but
not going to lie we kind of want Jonah
to Nitta something wouldn't that be a
good merch idea a personally knitted
present from Jonah sign us up we'd love
to get one never burped in one of their
interviews Zac revealed that he's never
been able to burp like ever support
other band members have pointed out this
is a fun fact he uses when he can't
think of anything else to say in another
interview he shared another embarrassing
secret he's the person that will fart
and then walk away pretending like
nothing happened come on Zac you can do
better than that other band members even
mocked him and told him how rude that is
it's definitely not a nice feeling to
smell that especially when it comes from
a superstar
can you imagine come to think of it it
would actually be hilarious to see Zac
do that in real life but the never burps
pact finally came to an end in August
2018 why don't we the fish'll twitter
account actually announced that zach has
finally learned how to burp and actually
burped for the first time in his life
Zac confirmed that it indeed happened
for the first time in 17 years we're not
sure that's an accomplishment someone
should ever admit to but let's be honest
it's pretty funny the fan incident we
all know how obsessed girls get when it
comes to boy bands we don't blame them
boy bands are just so dreamy and
just something about hearing them seeing
that makes our hearts melt just like one
direction why don't we have some pretty
intense fans or stands as Twitter would
call them they've yet to admit to any
crazy fan stories but we're sure that
will happen someday
although Corbin shared a really cute
story with BuzzFeed news this little fan
did exactly what we'd all do if we ever
met our Idol one little girl apparently
clung on to korban flake and she didn't
want to let go no matter what how
adorable is that her mom actually had to
come over and practically pull her off
so cute
why don't we boys still love their fans
but even superstars deserve to have
privacy and some personal space although
to be completely honest that probably
looks like it was the cutest thing ever
just imagine having a little girl not
willing to let you go after or during a
meet-and-greet
thank goodness her mom did the right
thing and pulled her away mostly there
weren't any tantrums involved foodie
here's another thing you should know
about Corbin he has a real food
obsession we're not just talking about
Chipotle we're talking about pretty much
everything
Corbin revealed his love for Italian
food and said that he loves dishes like
penne alla vodka which is a dish made of
penne and of course vodka it might sound
strange but it's actually really lovely
he admitted he also loves pizza and his
favorite toppings include pepperoni and
sausage
honestly we pretty much agree with all
of his food choices so far if you want
more examples of Corbin loving food just
check out his instant photos from the
world - word Borbon even shares his love
for food through relatable tweets like
this one which pretty much says who
needs a girlfriend when you can have
chips instead of course this should be
taken with a sense of humor but Corbin's
love for food can't be denied by the
looks of it Corbin doesn't really follow
a specific diet so he really is a man
after our own hearts so if you ever go
on a date with Corbin just take him to
an Italian restaurant he'll love it
looking for in a girl
but the questions why don't we boys get
asked the most revolve around girls it
makes sense right after all most of
their songs revolve around girls - we're
pretty sure girls are their bands
biggest fan base
the boys have pretty much been open
about their relationships with fans and
even admitted they wouldn't mind dating
a fan they also revealed plenty of
information on what they look for in a
girl and
cliche as it seems most of them just
want a cool girl with a nice personality
after all that's really what matters the
most doesn't it
Zack of course in his goofy way said
that the girl also has to smell good
which made his band members laugh the
truth is you just have to be yourself
and it's all good with these boys they
even admitted that they wouldn't mind
dating a fan from Texas and that Jack is
the one that tends to fall in love
immediately after the first date these
boys really do have a big heart and it's
only a matter of time before they find
someone that steals it forever and ever
of course some of them already have
found someone but that's the topic for
another video who's your favorite why
don't remember come share in the
comments below and that's it for our
video thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]